ich denke dass das ende von hero auf
jeden fall meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft text auf dem
heroes so war ich erzähle euch jetzt
erstmal wollte eigentlich kinos
aufnehmen allerdings war meine tanks
sind irgendwie total auch drogen ich
habe keine ahnung was los ist mit denen
der dating kam ich an
und das ist was anderes acht das ist
weil haben bei den also ich weiß nicht
ich spiele gerade irgendwie alles
verrückt aber so harvey eklig das ist
natürlich auch hier oben ist dass auch
ich kann mal so zwischendurch durch die
ganze blöcke durch gucken
hier ist es wiederum nicht wieso ist das
ist das hingegen wegen cavs komischen da
kann man nicht durchgehen blog oder oder
weswegen ist dass da ein mangel an gut
ich hab keine ahnung ich finde diese
bäume so konnten hässlich
ich finde die echt eklig irgendwie
mittlerweile ich sagte er so cool dies
darf
was das genau ist weiß ich auch nicht
aber das ist ja zur sache wie sieht es
aus mit ihm über waren als ich
eigentlich mit kinos aufnehmen aber das
ist im zug und ist irgendwie verspätet
und keine ahnung eva grund hauptquartier
sind nicht viel entstanden hier
darstellt wird ein schoko bossard da und
da wären kopf hier ist auch noch da
knicks immer wieder zu königin gehen
ich treffe also das ist es zeit nicht
verhindert man dachte ich mir so als
ersatz nehme ich dann kev und denen die
auch aufnehmen wollten
allerdings waren die beiden irgendwie
die waren gerade dann fertig als ich
aufnehmen
als ich die gefragt hatte das war ein
bisschen komisch und das ist auch ein
bisschen komisch und sie so vor sich
geht
jetzt kenne ich mir nicht erklären ich
bin jetzt einfach mal die fristen
weil wenn ich als er nicht am haus
weiter bauen kann wegen der ganzen
klasse dann mache ich jedoch einfach mal
so ein bisschen ich werde die andere
frisur allerdings bei ihm verzaubern und
sag euch was ich sonst doch so jetzt
machen werde hier und zwar meinte cap
irgendwas von wegen er hat mir etwas in
meinen dings getan in meinen keller so
von wegen ja du ich hab dir da was rein
getan das ist ganz gut für deine
essensausgabe und so okay aber ich mich
dann bedankt und dann schauen uns das
mal an was er da gemacht hat
ich weiß gar nicht wo er das gemacht hat
meinte ein kenner gemacht aber
vielleicht jeder eine ja wahrscheinlich
hier ja hier auch man wie macht ihr das
denn da ich wollte doch da hinten hin
machen vor allem was los hier
ich kann zwischendurch immer durch alles
durch wenn ihr denn ihr wisst wie ich
das löse dann schreibt mir das mal bitte
was ist echt grad ein bisschen ab
ein bildchen ein bisschen komisch wie
seid ihr eigentlich keinen namen musste
meinen namen berri frederiks kaktus
cloud printing press und grabstein gut
so aluminium später mal irgendwann ist
letzter zeit keinen krieg glaube ich
oder ist krieg ich weiß nicht dem und
stege für die es immer krieg ja und dann
kann man es eigentlich auch schon wieder
die rüstung aussehen mag es nicht wenn
ich die ganze zeit so gut verlaufe das
bisschen blöd weil ich mal eigentlich im
haus weiter bauen aber das funktioniert
jetzt nicht wenn ich die ganze diese
komischen fehler habe aber naja ich
brauche einfach mal ich glaub ich setze
hier sogar unseren komischen anderen
blocken
also ich verstehe dass ich nicht weiß
dass patti smith ist denn los mit dir
keine ahnung was das ist so hier kommt
das gleiche dann hin kann ich euch auch
gleich weg nehmen hier und zwar wollte
ich diese folge auch eigentlich ganz
gerne mal alleine aufnehmen um euch so
zu fragen was ihr sehen wollt auf meinem
kanal also mal wieder so gern sehen
wollt jetzt nicht irgendwie so lars
weibel games oder so sondern irgendwie
weise nicht eine bestimmte mod oder eben
big days oder das war jetzt fehlt ihm
mehr zeit habe und so wirklich nur ein
bisschen mehr zeit als vorher
die werde ich dann halt auch ein youtube
investieren weil ich halt in letzter
zeit sogar normale nahezu nichts hier
probt fremd für youtube gemacht hat dass
das tut mir leid das muss ich auch
zugeben ganz einfach dass der andere
viel mehr her kennen haben und viel
besser sich in hero informiert haben und
so aber ihr wisst dass freunde ich kann
nicht den ganzen tag mich dafür
informieren oder mit ihr hier dann seht
wie ich alles mögliche niederbayerische
dass das bin ich nicht dass es geht
das kann ich auch nicht tun weil meine
bei meinem zeitplan einfach nicht
mitspielt und ich hoffe einfach mal dass
ich folge ihm eine lampe gucken um zu
euch zu gucken fall komisch jemand
diesen gruppen regt mich dass opel die
sagt was passiert wenn die shader
einpacken
es ist immer noch da bei dem ist auch
noch da was mit dem song hat dabei der
shader hier ist cool und das ist das ist
gar kein richtiger schilder jetzt sogar
noch hässlicher irgendwie sondern nehmen
das ist gleich geld das wollte ich ihn
noch mal unterstellen wir dann das
einzel noch mal ein bisschen düsterer
aussieht ja das ist ein bisschen eklig
geraden ist ein bisschen eklig kann ich
denn da oben weiter waren einigermaßen
das ist auch abartig mano verde
irgendwas für die stadt hier tun
ich meine wenn ich ja eh schon nicht
essensausgaben so ein camper tier auch
woanders eingesetzt als ich eigentlich
wollte zauberstab jahre kaputt dann
sortiere ich kurz meine blöcke 1
rein und dann mache ich das mal übrigens
haben wir in der letzten zeit viele
leute gesagt meine stimme verpasst und
ist sollte ich doch noch mal umstellen
und ich habe das jetzt umgestellt und
meine stimme hat jetzt nahezu gar kein
gas mehr weil das vorher halt so richtig
gewöhnt hat und so dass wahrheit fanden
die meist nämlich nicht so geil ich fand
ihn ja auch nicht so dass ich mir dann
nach jahren mal wieder eine aufnahme von
mir angeguckt habe und naja jedenfalls
hab das jetzt mal umgestellt wartet habe
ich mich noch in der u6 ist aluminium du
blöd ist aluminium so dass prosieben mit
ich nehme ich mit da lasse ich mal hier
aber gras welt kohl habe ich da habe ich
bin da nicht da hab ich nämlich nicht
da muss ich auch mal fertig kriegen und
kisten sortieren er kiste sollt ihr name
das gras bisschen gras nehme ich mit
immer gut leben er wollte meine hexe
eigentlich hingelegt so dann hätte ich
mal alle sachen die ich hab also darum
gerät kann ich ihnen einfach mal mit
seinem buch auf dem kopf schlagen
der eishockey 3.0
also muss auch angezeigt werden
irgendwie ausgemacht so dann packe hier
so ein paar das ist kann ich meine
unnötiges kiste das hier sind unnötige
auch nicht ich muss echte kisten
sortiert das ist also der händen ja das
ist was sie machen muss
bitte nicht den rucksack voll u
wenn du mein spiegel ruck wirkt etwas
länger nicht gespielt
so hab ich nämlich auch mit jetzt marien
das noch mal
ach doch sony
doch ich kann als nicht kann ich nicht
irgendwie jetzt so bekomme ich nur diese
passen dass henkel platten hinten das
coole teile
wenn ich damit so fenster scheiße bauen
aber das ist so kacke dass das ganze
ding hier einfach nicht
das ist auch irgendwie voll nicht
geladen das ist mega eklig ich sehe
schon kommen
conny dislike angst davor was für sie
blöd aus ich glaub ich muss das noch mal
zahlen
die habe ich das dem urteil diese
anderem auch gar keiner textur irgendwie
habe ich dann fängst du ich hab auch
irgendwie dass das bild des bedrängnis
mein haus kleiner zu bauen das ist
irgendwie so groß oder ich verkleide das
wirklich auf diese platt auf die elf die
da auf diesem platz und dann mache ich
da so ein getrenntes kisten lager hin
klappt so mache ich das ja erst mal
brauche ich dafür ein bisschen novitäten
das hier habe ich das gemacht
a8
jetzt bekomme ich viel hiervon das sind
diese coolen ja das sind die coolen nee
nee da mache ich mir mich davon jetzt
erstmal phase wird dass diese zahl weil
sie nicht das muss reichen
und dann mache ich so so wollte ich gar
nicht er kann ich die auch hier sieht
ein bisschen aus wie school aus hasi der
mega los obwohl geht es nur halbe nicht
sogar besser leben erstmals ausprobieren
hier mit euch so dann mache ich das mit
denen hier auch nochmal so ein bisschen
dampf
die ganz kleinen hier kommen noch ein
paar ganz kleiner jeder fahrer von einst
hier so kommt euch hier meinte man gönnt
sich ja sonst nichts im leben freude so
so 64 davon und jetzt gehen hat nämlich
mal an
selbst ein bisschen ich meine wie
connect bringt auch nichts ich hatte
vorhin auch schon mal den fehler ich
hab's halt nicht irgendwie weg bekommen
ich hatte jetzt erstmal so gedacht dass
ich auf meinem haus nahezu alles so hin
baue was man so braucht also meine
essensausgabe macht dann sowie die
wahlurne und stelle hier hin quasi
selbst auch ganz kleine von diesen
teilen oh jetzt muss in dieser folge
richtig durchziehen damit ich hier nicht
umsonst die ganze scheiße geschnitten
habe jetzt wieder gemacht
ich weiß aber wie kann ich will diese
scheiß klicken marie panel so das sind
die kleinen oder sind es die kleinen
nicht immer noch kleiner
ohne spaß wir sind einfach noch kleiner
mann wie viel arbeit gibt man sich damit
der kacke es ist jetzt nicht wahr
leute mir soll es egal sein ich mach das
ding hier nur daneben dass es in etwa so
aussieht aber das kann ich nicht sagen
hier dass ich mich jetzt hier so eine
scheiße hier fabrizierte ohne so da voll
krass dass das hier auch noch so komisch
ist wir gehen das auch so bis hier breit
ist das teil 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 hat
man hier kommen auf jeden fall welche
hin
währenddessen könnte ich eine frage
beantworten die menschen aufgestellt
wurde war wie kommt es dazu dass du so
unfassbar geil bis nein spaß es wird ja
auch oft falsch verstanden
wenn ich dann so was sagen conny men
star
das ist ja alles immer noch spaß viele
leute verstehen das dann immer so als ob
ich das zu ernst meine sodass ich fühle
mich alt bin und dies ist ein anderes
aber nein die die echten leute glaube
ich unter euch die begreifen dass die
haben den verstand dafür dass das ironie
ist was ist denn da für block ist
eigentlich relativ scheißegal ich
glaubte sich einfach mal eher dahin war
ich von ehrengästen habe dann war sagt
das kam dass dies in der essence
vermehrt ist weil sonst ein schimmel
vielleicht ist es also keine ahnung so
hier kommt babbel hin
das dach kommen das ist marvel
cobblestone mir soll es egal sein es ist
die essens ausgearbeitet ist mein
gebäude von daher weder dort gebaut hat
ich meine meine damen und herren und ich
habe kein makel mehr sah
denen sage ich mir als neuen kabel kabel
ich bin ein kabel das ist der schnee den
unsere und in unsere chance von königin
wenig erlaubt hat ich fragte gar nix
mehr
einen tag vor ende vor ende ihrer
amtszeit bringe ich die um ich schwere
reich schwerst euch wirklich machen
attentat auf die 4
ich brauch neuen marvel unsere ganze
stadt besteht auch einfach keinen
zauberstab hab ich denn hin gekappt
unsere ganze stadt norderstedt ein form
aber ich werd ich finde einfach auch
nicht mal was doch die vorne war auch so
eine blöde mit marvel die da vier
händler beste leben des ortes so jedoch
relativ schnelle mit neben überreden was
kann ich leben keine ahnung
das ende von i will dann wird er oft
gesagt dass hiro so enden wird wie das
megaprojekt weil das ja in
in unseren städten jetzt hier immer so
was das hier eigentlich
aluminium diese verdammte cracks aus
aluminium
warum sagt wenn das denn nie einer pizza
schreibt mir das nochmal in die
kommentare
danach galt doch nicht mein job oft
bietet könnte ich jetzt überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen
das ja geil fünf aluminium oder können
wir vielleicht doch bald diese komischen
hart kenntnis da machen wenn ihr dann
genau beschreibt wie ich das benutzen
soll in die kommentare spend mich zu mit
der hand mit dem mit eurem wissen
freunde also viele meinen ja echt dass
das megaprojekt schon dass ich hier auch
sehr gut in der 16 minute mit dem thema
anzufangen
klasse luca du bist so gut vorbereitet
wie also viele meinen das ist hero
angeblich so zu ende gehen wird wie das
mega projekt quasi zu ende gegangen ist
weil das ganze jetzt schon irgendwie so
eine falsche richtung läuft weil krieg
mit den königin besteht ich bin nicht
einverstanden ich sagen königinnen
ich bin nicht einverstanden mit der
königin stadtrodas nicht einverstanden
mit der stadt geld werde könig jetzt
weiß ich gar nicht ich war david auf
jeden fall nicht mehr schaffen nicht
weil nix reist also der lebt nicht so
hoch mal nicht so nach dem motto wandern
könnte ich mir gut vorstellen oder ich
bin mir gerade nicht sicher werden statt
wie ein könig ist ich bin ja auch nicht
könig deswegen bin ich auch nicht mehr
könig scampis da ist anders jedenfalls
ist es halt so dass oft auch krieg
herrschen dass einige leute auch bei uns
in den conti zum einen soll ja das ist
doch nicht gut wenn man auf einen server
geht und so blase sind normale
diskussionen da streitet sich jetzt
keiner und
nicht so wie ihr das dann immer so denkt
zu teilweise ein paar zuschauer denken
immer durch auch die streiten sich
untereinander wenn sie sich gegenseitig
umbringen
ich bin voll
beispielsweise thema weg fünf vorhaben
noch ein bisschen marble deswegen dem
ich noch was mit mega projekt war es am
ende auch so dass die leute sehr sehr
unzufrieden waren weil dann auf einmal
den new kids mit hut und einer den
ganzen brief abbekommen und das
eigentlich voll zu unrecht ist er noch
was das eigentlich ist da noch was etwa
wenn wir schon mal aluminium finden dann
nehmen wir das natürlich alles mit meine
damen und herren
warum den ganzen brief castiel weil bei
denen auch etwas in der luft gesprengt
wurde und und sowas im mega projekt aber
in liebe und wenig ist das ganze super
organisiert durch die ganzen regeln dass
wenn man stirbt auch nicht mehr hoch
laden darf deswegen will man noch
versichert mehr seine attentate aktion
machen weil sie auch regeln gegen gibt
dass man nichts von anderen leuten
zerstören darf und so verschiedene
sachen auch ich dachte schon dass wir
weg aber es ist einfach nicht weg und
ich denke eigentlich dass sich da hero
nicht selbst herstellen wird also ich
denke dass das ende von hero auf jeden
fall am tag wobei sie nicht irgendwas
heftiges passiert halt dann ist aber
gerade der schrott den ich wollte ja
hinten oder ich wollte erst mal gucken
ob dieses sachen ach ich habe ja mit
circa abgebaut dass er besser leben kann
ja direkt hier noch eine minute richtig
geil aber immer noch eine folge auch von
mach ich das dann in der nächsten folge
fällig dann gehe ich wieder vom server
ich hoffe dass danach besser ist ich
kann nichts versprechen
also ich denke dass hier wohl eine art
endlos projekt sein wird und
dementsprechend sollte da eigentlich nix
anderen also das sollte eigentlich immer
weiter laufen finde ich würde am
liebsten jetzt direkt weiter bauen aber
ich muss jetzt einfach das video beenden
deswegen sage ich mal leute wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lasst einfach eine
bewertung da das wird mich freunde mir
zeigen ob ihr so was mögt und ich bin
mega bleichen der fans kennen
diese lampe die ich hab ne die macht so
grelles weißes licht das ist mega eklig
aber gut wie es beim nächsten mal
wiederholen was gut und teuer